perfect song for this
all month long we are celebrating
women's history month by talking with
female leaders in sports and politics
business and entertainment
and how about publishing too this
morning we're joined by two women
who've inspired millions to unleash
their power and know their worth
retired usa soccer star that's abby
wambach is a two-time olympic gold
medalist
and a world cup champion thank you very
much her wife that's glennon doyle
is a new york times best-selling author
thank you very much her memoir
untamed has sold more than two million
copies and it's still selling worldwide
you go glenn
doyle is also the founder of together
rising that's a non-profit run by women
they join us only
on cbs this morning good morning to you
both
let's start with this pandemic hi girls
it's so good to see you
and i know you both have thoughts on
this because millions of women have left
the workforce because of the pandemic
has forced them that they've got to stay
at home they're leaving the workforce
abby i want you to start us off with
this what do you think needs to change
here because we're aware of our
responsibilities at work
our responsibilities at home but we're
choosing home now because we have no
choice what needs to change here
abby start us off please well i mean a
lot of
corporations need to step up and support
women
in the roles that they have at work
support their home lives
and also husbands we all need to
understand that
we are equal human beings women need to
be paid equally
that is why women are stepping away from
their workforce because it's logic
whoever's making more money
you know is gonna stay in their
workforce in the work in their work life
and then
the one who's making less goes home so
women need to get paid more we deserve
it
yes yes yes i second that emotion
glennon your book untamed
still flying off the shelves i love what
adele said about your book
to readers it will shake your brain and
make your soul scream
uh we all need some of that but you have
said this women strive to be good at
everything we're trying to be a good
mother a good daughter a good partner a
good citizen
and instead we're finding ourselves left
over weary
stuck and unfulfilled so what do you say
to women who are struggling right now
a lot of people can resonate those words
resonate with a lot of people
yeah well the first thing i would say is
you're not alone i mean i know from
running together rising which is a
non-profit that supports women and
children
in need that many many many many people
are struggling right now
and so what i'm saying right now is
let's just lower our expectations
let's get through this time and just
survive not try to be amazing just get
through and then in the after
let's bring let's not forget let's not
forget what this time has revealed about
what has always been true which is that
women are holding up much more than half
the sky
and let's go into the after creating
families
homes corporations that have
us at the table to build them so we're
included yeah
hey glenn and it's anthony i i wanted to
ask you we see your book cover behind
you it's being made into a tv
series what can you tell us about that
um i can tell you that it's really
really exciting i'm learning all about
the tv world which is much different
than books
and i'm not we have an actor but i'm not
allowed to tell you who it is but it's
so exciting give us give us initials
give us some initials give us an issue
you're going to get in trouble no you
know i can't keep secret scale don't
pressure me okay all right all right
we'll move on all right so ladies you
know we love a love story here
at cbs this morning and untamed is a
love story uh
and we have the uh meet cute uh from
glendon's perspective here you say when
you saw
abby my whole being says there she
is abby i'm curious what was it like
from your side of things
[Laughter]
um so she stood up
okay and stretched her arms out
this wide and we were in a room full of
other people who were eating at a table
so i felt like i needed to know
she made it pretty awkward like oh i
need to now go and greet her because she
made it
made it so so i got around to her um
you know and at first i thought who is
this person what is she doing
and then when we embraced there was
electricity
from the get-go i've never experienced
anything like that
so i know that she writes about it as
love at first sight and it's true it's
both side
both sides love it first it sounds like
it because lennon said listen you had
been married to a man you had children
but abby walked in the room and you go
it was a wrap that was it i'm curious
about what you saw but abby i want to
know about the
wolf pack because i love what you say
wear what you want love who you love
become what you can imagine
women don't wait anymore could you just
elaborate on that in the short time that
we have with the two of you
yeah so the whole concept that i learned
from playing on the national team for so
long
is that we women because we've been
margin marginalized for so
for forever really we need to use each
other
we need to work in packs so that's why i
named it wolf pack yeah
um i wrote about all the principles that
i learned about leadership on the
national team
and really i mean glennon is an untamed
is exactly the methodology you have to
actually figure out
your own individual self first before
you can pack up yes
you gotta be a cheetah and a wolf yeah
yeah and i love what you said at barnard
in 2018
give me the ball give me the job give me
the same pay as the guy next to me
that sums it up pretty nicely don't be
grateful anymore it's time to
take action all right abby want back
glennon doyle thank you both very much
we appreciate you good to see both of
you thank you